[Música]
hola y bienvenidos a revista digital
donde abordamos los temas más
importantes del ciberespacio las redes
sociales y los medios de comunicación de
américa latina y el mundo
ante la situación de kobe 19 ahora
trabajamos desde casa la nueva escalada
de tensiones entre israel y palestina ha
llamado la atención mundial en redes
sociales sean viralizado las imágenes
del intercambio de ataques entre las
fuerzas israelíes y las milicias
palestinas en gaza y en los que han
muerto más de 80 personas desde ambos
territorios sus residentes han usado
internet para contarle al mundo su
versión de los hechos pero muchos
denuncian que sus esfuerzos se han visto
frenados por lo que califican como
censura por parte de los operadores de
las plataformas digitales qué está
pasando allí empezamos
imágenes de lo que sucede entre israel y
palestina han traspasado fronteras en
parte gracias a las redes sociales el
pasado 11 de mayo el mundo vio con
asombro una lluvia de cohetes sobre la
ciudad de tel aviv en israel unos 130
proyectiles fueron lanzados por milicias
palestinas desde la franja de gaza
controlada por el grupo hamas
la mayoría fueron interceptados por el
sistema antimisiles del ejército pero
algunos lograron golpear suelo israelí
el suceso fue registrado en internet
como israel and fire o israel bajo fuego
por su parte cientos de vídeos de
edificaciones en ruinas se publicaban
bajo el numeral gasa under attack o gasa
bajo ataque refiriéndose a la ofensiva
aérea de israel contra este territorio
durante varios días ambas fuerzas han
protagonizado el peor intercambio de
hostilidades desde 2014 al momento de
grabar este programa el ministerio de
salud de gaza reportó que más de 80
palestinos entre ellos 18 menores
murieron desde que iniciaron los ataques
israelíes el pasado 10 de mayo mientras
que en israel se contaban 7 muertos pero
como se produjo esta situación
estos nuevos episodios de violencia
tienen su origen a mediados de abril al
inicio del ramadán el mes sagrado del
islám y que celebra la mayoría de los
palestinos
la policía israelí instaló barricadas
frente a la puerta de damasco una de las
entradas a la ciudad vieja lo que los
musulmanes denunciaron como una
restricción para impedir sus
tradicionales reuniones nocturnas
después del ayuno la situación de
ariguaní enfrentamientos entre civiles y
uniformados y aunque las barreras fueron
removidas las protestas continuaron
ahora en rechazo al desalojo de familias
palestinas en el barrio de sheikh jarrah
de jerusalén este para dar paso a
colonos israelíes en el complejo de la
mezquita de al-aqsa el tercer sitio más
sagrado para los musulmanes es la
policía israelí usó granadas
lacrimógenas y balas de goma mientras
que los manifestantes lanzaron piedras y
botellas cientos de personas resultaron
heridas el grupo hamas había dado un
ultimátum a israel para retirar sus
fuerzas tanto de al-aqsa como de sheikh
jarrah y después de esto lanzó los
primeros cohetes
lo que sucede en el barrio shej jarrah
ha sido uno de los temas más discutidos
en internet esto debido a una campaña
llamada 66 guerra o salvemos a segarra y
que tomó fuerza en los últimos días este
vecindario en el esté ocupado de
jerusalén está habitado en su mayoría
por familias palestinas una ley israelí
permite a los judíos reclamar terrenos
allí si pueden probar que les
pertenecían antes de la guerra de 1948
tras la creación del estado de israel
sin embargo no existe una ley similar
para los palestinos que perdieron sus
hogares en este mismo conflicto a través
del numeral segarra los promotores de
esta iniciativa han divulgado
testimonios de las personas afectadas no
solo por la disputa legal sino por la
nueva escalada de tensiones su objetivo
es crear conciencia y lograr que la
presión de la comunidad internacional
detenga los desalojos
pero los intentos por contarle al mundo
lo que está pasando entre israel y
palestina se han visto reprimidos en
redes sociales según denuncian usuarios
la mayoría de ellos palestinos a
principios de mayo reportaron que
instagram estaba eliminando contenido
relacionado con sheikh jarrah la empresa
respondió que se trataba de una falla
global pero las denuncias continuaron
durante los últimos días usuarios en
twitter también reportaron la suspensión
de sus cuentas que la compañía atribuyó
a la violación de sus reglas más de 20
organizaciones defensoras de los
derechos digitales como access nabo y
artículo 19 hicieron un llamado para que
haya claridad en el asunto
esta última serie de eliminación de
contenido es parte de un patrón más
amplio de censura constante de las voces
palestinas y aliadas y los esfuerzos
sistemáticos para silenciar los que las
organizaciones de la sociedad civil han
documentados durante años las
plataformas de redes sociales brindan un
espacio crucial para las comunidades que
no tienen otro recurso para hacer que se
escuchen sus demandas de libertad
justicia y dignidad la forma en que los
medios de comunicación han cubierto la
situación entre israel y palestina ha
sido objeto de varios titulares
folha de sao paulo en brasil dice que
los palestinos rechazan la cobertura
deshumanizada de los enfrentamientos con
israel por su parte el periódico israelí
'the jerusalem post'
criticó en su titular ignorando el
lanzamiento de cohetes desde gaza la
mayoría de medios extranjeros se centran
en los ataques aéreos de israel el medio
de noticias miro liz ai con sede en
londres titula israel-palestina un
glosario de lenguaje mediático
problemático en el que rescata la labor
de una serie de activistas que señalan
como los términos utilizados por los
medios distorsionan la narrativa
de jerusalén mientras que el periódico
británico metros reportó que la cadena
bbc se vio obligada a crear una página
dedicada a las quejas sobre su cobertura
entre israel y palestina' ya que los
espectadores citaron informes con
prejuicios aunque en redes sociales
circularon capturas de pantalla de dicha
página ya no está disponible en internet
hasta aquí revista digital recuerde que
si quiere repetir esta u otra misión de
nuestro programa lo puede hacer a través
de nuestra página web www puntos y
cuatro puntos
[Música]